Italy's radical new government has
caused plenty of consternation here in
Brussels since it was elected but is its
bark worse than its bite my guest this
week is the Italian MEP Fabio cast Aldo
who's also a vice-president of the
European Parliament after urging Britain
to stand up to the EU on brexit why did
his government leave Theresa May in the
lurch at last week's critical EU summit
[Music]
Fabio cassava welcome to conflict zone
thank you very much
let's hope brexit first of all along
with other members of your coalition
you've been urging the British
government to take a tough line with
Brussels and you specifically promised
to help get Britain's the brexit they
want why did you break that promise at
Salzburg last week your government broke
that promise I'm sorry about that I
didn't see and it asked them to be as
such as tough as possible balsa just saw
them that the Italian government is
ready to support them in a good
negotiation and can satisfy everybody
satisfied Brussels on one hand and
satisfy all so they need in the desire
of the British government - you said
especially you said provide all possible
support in the council and in all
discussion forums to ensure a
satisfactory deal for everyone and
especially for the British government
and British people so your delegation at
Salzburg stayed absolutely silent when
all Tereza Mays proposals were rejected
out of hand
you said nothing did nothing said
nothing we understood that in this
moment there is a kind of blockade and
we can see unfortunately that the steps
that we were waiting for for an ordinate
backseat are not yet all here and we
think that the failure of the
negotiations and the brexit without any
kind of legal framework and agreement
would be disaster bought for london
bought for the you because we know very
well that in any case UK government and
UK as a country will be a crucial
partner for us not just from it from the
commercial point of view but also for
the security of the content let's not
forget but this was a critical summit
last week this was critical milestone
and you said nothing
the 27 the the report from the European
Council said the 27 were in full
agreement so you didn't offer any help
to Mrs May whatsoever no because we are
still trying to we do not want to break
up the front of the negotiation but at
the same time inside the front of the 27
we are playing the lure or the role of
the mediator we are playing the role
that is trying to approach and to
strengthen a bit the negotiations and to
find a [ __ ] in a negotiation to fight
when all compromise solution you've
already said that the EU has a negative
attitude to Britain full of suspicion
and arrogance this is Ignacio Correa
this is money one of your people one of
your people yes but this is not me I
guess is the view of many people inside
the five star party is also the view of
Matteo salvini your interior minister
yes that is not belong part of the
coalition that is not part of the five
stars movement and our attitude I repeat
once more is to prevent any attempt to
do any kind of punishment towards the UK
government because we think rejecting
open mrs. mains proposals was punishment
sorry I am I do not understand why you
are seeing an attitude of mediator as a
negative issue because basically you are
telling me that if you are trying to
play the role of the mediator we are
doing something negative
you just media you said nothing when the
chips were down at the Salzburg you said
nothing that's what you are saying
because you know very well that the name
in the negotiations there are official
negotiation and there are backside
negotiation and in this case we think
that silent diplomacy can achieve better
results then do a kind of war with press
release and a kind of worth were with
public statement we want an excellent
diplomatic solution and diplomatic
solution normally to be effective should
be worked behind the scenes not in front
of the scenes but it's not happening is
it it not nothing yet but mrs. may said
the talks have reached an impasse so
much for your mediation you've reached
an impasse sorry sorry to say but we
have seen other in passes in the past
during this very difficult negotiation
because it's the first time that article
50 was activated and we know very well
that there is no tradition no custom how
to deal with such a negotiation because
it's the first case in history so it's
not a naturally doing some moment of the
negotiation we can find
blockade and impasse our work behind the
scenes even in front when necessary but
you can all be sciences as government
and here inside the European Parliament
is to trying to have a closer position
in this tough moment especially because
there doesn't seem so many signs of that
happening I want to talk if I may about
your coalition which is four months some
four months old it's a fragile coalition
because during the election that you
brought you into power you described the
league your coalition partners as the
real danger to Europe if you believe
that how long can this coalition last
you're in coalition with the biggest
danger the real danger to you first
first of all just tell me when I told
you because I've know you're not
positive but your party campaigned on of
course everybody was in campaign and I
think they're also in your country in
Germany when there was when the word
election I don't think they'd say they
would say that's s that the socialist by
Social Democratic Party was exactly the
best part in German this is an
unworkable coalition because you
disagree on fundamental issues don't you
you are like the migrants for in let me
say that this is your personal opinion
because we have a contract and this
contract was negotiating following the
German model and in this negotiation we
put some common points in which we can
agree and we do not have to agree in all
let's look at the things you don't
answer sorry because you are stopping me
and I would like to finish to finish my
explanation in this contract or
government we put some common items we
didn't put anything about having exactly
the same position on Europe we didn't
put anything about the partners we have
to would like to have in Europe so it
does not mean that we have to agree in
everything what is important to stick to
the program
stick to the goal that the contract of
government we got and to follow and to
turn into reality all the points it's
the crystal contract mr. Kaster do you
disagree on the fundamentally the
biggest issue facing Europe at the
moment which is the migrant issue you
disagree fundamentally with your
coalition partners on that mr. salvini
wants the Oban route the leader of
Hungary he wants the urban route no
migrants and you want to settle this
with Europe so there's a big gulf
between your two parties on this this is
golf no because the action of the
government in the last few European
summit in all the discussion of the of
the council was always
always to find and to implement what is
our position to it that means a
mandatory preventive redistribution
among the different countries and we
have asked that with a United position
of the government in all the different
forum maybe are not so much informed
about that but this is the reality of
the fact let's here I recognize the
mattel salvini sometimes is expressing
very tough and strong declaration by
these dunes is saying that on the autumn
of himself the action of the government
is sensibly different and we always ask
through the mouth of the only person
that is really in charge of this that
means the Prime Minister to implement
this position a common approach from all
the youth to reform the doubling system
and to share the response okay well
Islam on the car let's look at how much
you actually agree on the migrants
policy take the issue of sending
migrants back to Libya just this summer
roberto freako president of the Chamber
of Deputies member of your party spoke
out about a case in which almost 350
people attempting to reach Italy was
sent back to Libya as Foucault put it
Libya is not a safe landing point human
rights are not guaranteed so migrants
can't be left there mr. salvini says
that's lies let's let's who's lying
who's lying here may I answer yes the
point is very clear I do not know if you
have been in Libya I have been in lis
because I have been three months ago and
I saw the situation of the ground of
course this is a very terrible situation
because it depends on which part of the
country we are there are different
different level of cognition of controls
by the different militias and the
different governments what the human
rights groups are saying about the
treatment of migrants were sent back of
course and salvini says that's lies and
of course in our opinion and our
position is very clear still nowadays
there are problems of human rights
violation in in Libya and I would like
to thank I am and the other
international organization from event
for the excellent work we are doing on
the ground with very difficult condition
basically because Libya because of the
action also some European governments in
the last year's was left in the hands of
militias
and was left in the hands of not
official authorities the point is since
the cast out that let's be clear here
some a lot of these migrants are being
sent back to what Amnesty International
Code horrific abuse including torture
forced labor extortion and unlawful
killing at the hands of Libyan
authorities smugglers and armed groups
you may sleep more easily in your bed at
night because there are fewer migrants
coming to your country but this is the
kind of treatment that they receive when
you send them back to Libya exactly you
care or don't you I of course I care but
I would like to ask you if mr. mrs.
Angela Merkel is carrying when he sent
back to Turkey after the legal agreement
what is your point of view of the legal
agreement that was done between you and
Turkey an agreement is not respecting
the legal basis represent anyone you
represent a political policy and I am
Telling You that in this moment we are
seeing clearly that Europe is not able
or Europe not my country all Europe is
not able to face the problem because the
position to have an agreement with Libya
and was not just about from the Italian
government was backed by all the new
countries and all European Union as
usual speak out against what human
rights is one of your responsibilities
why don't you bang the drum about the
because it is that these people are
getting at the hands of the Libyan
authorities because I had many time I
denounce that also in the planner and I
say we have to pretend respect from the
Libyan authorities of the Human Rights
we have to do more to protect it's not
happening but it's not happening you can
talk all you want but it's not happy
it's not happening even the improvement
of the state of ruler law in Turkey
after the agreement with a that was
pushed by so these are lousy agreements
all of them of colossi agree they we are
trying just to move the the problem
inside other countries to try to hide
the problem inside the carpet but the
problem is still there but it was a
problem in Italy itself you happy with
the way migrants were kept for days on a
boat in August as the Interior Minister
mr. salvini refused to let them in
support that the terrible consequence of
the fact that the use does not want to
solve the problem for how many years the
different color governors asked for a
joint solution to reform the Dublin
system there is not what about his
decision to keep certain
members of your party were very upset by
this Gilda spot yellow said the decision
not to allow the rescue ship to
disembark is not shared by me
it cannot belong to my any of us we
express concerns and we say this is not
the solution but I cannot understand
that that would remain to blame by the
or it may I answer that I cannot
understand after many years of silence
silence by our our partners of hypocrisy
by mr. Mac Ron that is blaming on us but
at the same time it militarized the
border with Italy in Ventimiglia
militarized all the west border of Italy
and Israel and all there are also
massive reports from the human rights
NGO about violation by the French
authorities in the French police about
the right of the migrants well what is
the the answer the European answer on
that this is unfortunately falling from
people the sense of insecurity is
usually on this where's your answer to
lock people up on a boat to stop them
disembark if it's not my answer this is
the answer of the Ministry of Interior
that implement that and these are the
people you brought into government let's
remember you won the election and you
brought the league into government so
you share instability for what the
league does as well and that's why we
say that we want an European solution
but still nowadays what is the attitude
from our partners to solve the problem
we again will repeat for example let's
stress change the mandates of the
mission of the Sofia mission let's try
to share again the harbor's in the
Mediterranean then go to take all the
responsibility or at least let's say
that all these migrants that will come
and it'll then they will be there
distributed from Haitian again and no 27
know what Italy what why my country has
to deal with 700 thousand migrants all
along this is the European solidarity
okay let's looking for who this is the
European legislation let's look closer
to her mr. Castell how did you feel when
your country's interior minister posted
a slogan on his Facebook and Twitter
accounts on the anniversary of
Mussolini's birthday a slogan that was
almost exactly the same as the one used
by the wartime fascist dictator only a
few words changed salvini wrote so many
enemies
so much honor Mussolini's saying was
many enemies much honor how did you feel
about I didn't know about that and if it
happened probably it has you haven't
heard
you know and do you know nothing about
this no there was a huge coverage in
your own papers as well sincerely if we
did such a kind of communication this is
not an appropriate one into she should
not have done this and I hope it will
clarify that there is there is nothing
to do with the fascist pessimist fascist
apology vincenzo Spadafora from your
party says under secretary to the Prime
Minister's Office
he said he warned against using slogans
that relate to dark times in Italian
history you agree with her I absolutely
agree with chance Espada for is a good
friend of mine and many time has report
his battles and its position on defense
of human rights and equal opportunities
as undersecretary general for equal
opportunities in Italy and of course I
think that all ministers of the
government of every single government
should be very careful on the
communication they are using and to
clarify that there is in any case any
doubts about any possible
misunderstanding about former slogan of
exactly director mr. mr. spera for I was
speaking after Daisy a circle a black
discus thrower on Italy's athletics team
was hit by an egg in an apparent racist
attack she suffered an eye injury and
she said the racial attitudes in Italy
had got worse in the past I've
experienced insults but now I see in
this country she said attention that
unifies prejudice and frustrations
sometimes leading to extreme incidents
is that the kind of country you want is
that why you entered government tell me
you're not inform about the fact that
the authors of this aggression to this
athlete one of them it was the child of
a Democratic Party counselor maybe you
didn't read enough our news it doesn't
matter she's talking she's talking about
attitudes unification of prejudice and
frustrations in Italy and we don't want
exactly and I also denounced that but
then we discover that those those guys
that one of them is son of one counselor
local counsel of the Democratic Party so
that means that we have to fight all
together on this regard and nobody can
be just blamed by himself by what is
risk because one person is educated in
the family that is left-wing
and is educating in a family in which
one of the parent is actively
participant to politics for one of the
party that was accusing the government
for that so that means that is a common
risk this is not an isolated case is it
this is we now know that your coalition
probably you didn't know about we now
know that your coalition partner the
leak has brought a defamation case
against a politician code Cecile kianga
sure she's a member of the European
Parliament was Italy's first black
government minister she accused the
League of racism they denied the charge
and are fighting back through courts but
whatever the legal merits of this case
she was deeply insulted wasn't she
she's equality is my colleague here in
the European Parliament and know her
very well and my members are doing I was
insulted commitment here another huge
respect for our work and of course
sentences by the law by the tribunal
should be respected by everybody as well
we said in every single case that is
concerning every single politician from
any single party so we will wait for
what just he will say and we will
pretend that the branch is condemned the
thing some of the league politicians
have said why don't you can that because
we cannot enter culturally a league
senator said in 2013 when I see Miss
kianga I am unable not to think about
although I don't say that it is the
appearance of an orangutan unfortunately
the gods accept totally for your remarks
we condemns that many times and we said
we do not want have to have anything to
do with this kind of declaration maybe
you are not inform about the present is
and many times we did on this regard and
these are the people you still wanted to
have in your coalition I remember I
would like to remember that when we
proposed to Matteo Renzi to form a
government together and we propose to
Matteo Renzi the democratic party to
have a government together he said no
way we don't want to negotiate we said
we are ready to negotiate every single
issue and joint program for the
government of next five five years in
Italy and even if was not Secretary
General was part anymore it blocked
every single possibility to negotiate so
tell me what was the solution to live in
Italy with other government to do not
have any kind of government in power to
take the terrible issues we are facing
economical crisis possible Bank crisis
immigrants issue everything what we have
to do
we try to negotiate with all two
possible partners okay let's look at
something else your partners are doing
the league's families Minister Lorenzo
Fontana
yes proposal to scrap the anti-fascist
manche no law which was passed in 1993
to outlaw racist violence and hates we
defend his law and we say that is not
going to happen because it's not on the
program of the contractor of this
government and that's why it will never
happen because it was not negotiated we
stick to the god the promises we kept
and we stick to the contract we
negotiate so this is not going to happen
what makes this especially controversial
is that they attempt to scrap the
anti-fascist law is happening just at
the same time as mr. Savini is being
investigated under it so is this what
happens now in Italy ministers find laws
inconvenient so they seek to scrap the
laws yeah I'm sorry to say that and I
repeat once more that this is not going
to happen because we are the main
partner of this coalition and we say
that this issue is not in the contract
of the government and for this reason
this is not going to be supported voted
or presented by five stars movement that
means there are no numbers in Parliament
to vote such an abrogation of such a law
we are going to defend that and if they
are lega Nord members are doing such a
declaration you should ask them to
blacken or because on behalf of five
stars I can repeat once more that this
law is not going to be changed because
for us anti-fascism is a value and the
defense of the values of the resistance
and of those people who fight to free
our country are a value the problem for
you though is that the league's
right-wing populism
is raising them up in the pinyon polls
where your five star movement is falling
back savviness rhetoric is catching
honestly the poll in August shows his
handling of the migrant crisis that won
over some 50% of your voters according
to a poll in La Repubblica
poll of republika they are not the truth
say very clearly that if you know that
you're losing in the opinion polls no
star movement is losing I would like to
tell you that
according to all the polls almost all
the polls they were published in the
last months maybe we can have lost one
point or two but the one who's
collapsing is mr. Berlusconi force
Italia that had in the last election 13
and still in your party very early
represented in 14% of them all the votes
during the last lecture and now around
six seven percent so almost all the new
voters that are supporting mr. self in
action are coming from force Italia of
mr. Berlusconi and yet you're so worried
about your image that you've taken to
attacking the Italian media Luigi de
Meyer says some papers are polluting the
political debate every day I don't read
Italian newspapers to be informed he
said but I don't need to understand how
they want to attack us welcome to
democracy mr. Castell if you don't like
the heat why are you in government sorry
to say that but here what we was then
instead it was not the role of media
because we always fought for free
media's and independency and free the
freedom of opinion what would the
president have remember you didn t or in
the pro-life I would like to answer if
you allow me without blocking me every
30 seconds when I'm expressing concept
thank you very much I would like to tell
you that in this case about newspapers
what we are the Nazis in the conflict of
interest and I would like to give us
some examples
did you everybody of us so in the
media's what happened about the collapse
of the bridge in Genoa okay when we
denounce it what happened the fact that
the maintenance was cut every single
year for more than 10 years by the
business company that is managing all
this infrastructure no newspaper was
publishing the name of the main
shareholders that are controlling this
big business this is a reason to try to
take advertisement you know go ahead and
saying that this big business company
this family is financing many newspaper
is taking some action municipal
newspaper so we didn't say that we want
to close these newspapers what we ask is
that these newspapers should publish and
very clearly in the newspaper who are
the shareholders who are the investors
that are financing this newspaper
because
but it was me you everybody else when
they are buying a newspaper we should
know if this newspaper should be
influenced it has died the owners and
their profit interest or they are doing
exactly their job as publishers without
any kind of influence it's the custom to
know if your president was concerned
enough to remind your party that as he
put it the unconditional freedom of the
press is the cornerstone and fundamental
element of democracy shocking that you
need to be reminded of this no I don't
think I think that what the president
said is totally in his rights as his
position but we clarified that it is not
interfere because again we repeat we
won't like to have published in the
newspapers the name of the shareholders
that are controlling these newspapers
because in Italy we didn't solve the
issue of the conflict of interest and
this is says there's a civil war in the
european union between the pro-eu
liberals and the nationalist faction
which is Hungary Poland Czech Republic
as he sees it who's going to win and
what side are you on
personally I always say that the five
starts and will always at five stars
that want to be the third way in this
issue we do not want to be with macron
and with the old you said you won't
challenge the I always said it yeah now
it said that if we are not going to be
listen as a country consider that we're
an active contributor we are paying much
more than what you are getting we were
ready to rise the veto on the new budget
of you from 2020 2027 that is totally
alright because it what the treaty is
giving to us because we need a unanimity
approval approval and second of all I
would like to clarify a very single
issue from one side we have let's say
the nationalistic and sovereign approach
from the other side we have Mr McCrone
approach let's say that ideological is
pro-european but then from his concrete
policy day by day we see that it's very
nationalistic as well in their interests
of this country and is trying to deny
the reality of many problems we would
like to demo we will be going to channel
you are not going to challenge the
European Union sorry what does it mean
challenge we mr. DeMaio is your clarify
you say that we are ready if
we'll be no reform of the Dublin trade
if they will be noted from of eurozone
that we are ready to even think about
the possibility to use the bait so on
the next budget and this is our
prerogative as Germany can do as Austra
can do as Spain we can do just to be
listen and we will be with the weight
just to finish will be the third way and
we will try to criticize and to propose
actively reports on your at zone on
social Europe on migration not with
urban and not with macro we've run out
of time Fabio gastado thanks for being
on conflict zone thank you thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]